foreign
let's run out to St Louis Missouri and
talk to the one and only Jessica what's
up Jessica
hi thanks for taking my call of course
what's up appreciate it
um my question is
um how do I navigate feeling guilty when
my mom's trying to give me money
um and I feel like it'll add to her
financial burden
can you just say no
no
confidence
[Music]
um
do me a favor can you talk directly into
your phone sure oh much much better
perfect yeah all right so
we've been working on
um getting a down payment for a house
and my mom recently inherited some money
and so I would assume that that's where
the money kind of the conversation kind
of came into play
and she said that she wants to help
contribute
um to our mortgage I'm just really
worried about my mom
um and I don't know the whole picture of
like her financial situation but from
what I do know
um she just took out a second HELOC
um has credit cards that um and is that
retirement age and doesn't have a
retirement and so I if I if I were you I
would tell my mom
um
like I I got offers from people that I
care about to help with a down payment
of my first house and my answer even
then was no thank you
um I was super Blown Away by the offer
no that's not true the very very first
house I did I borrowed money I bought a
little bit of money and it was not wise
or smart it was really not wise
the next time I got an offer from
several people that I care about and I
said no thank you
I never want to live under that again I
would if I were you sit down with my mom
and say Mom the greatest gift you could
give me and my new husband in our house
is for you to not owe anybody any money
and for you to be safe and whole
would you be willing to
go through kind of your situation and
I'm happy to help in any way I can we
can apply this money but the greatest
gift you could give me is for you to be
safe
that's what I would say oh Jessica I'm
fine things are fine we're gonna be good
well that's great I I we are we are
great and we are good and I am so
grateful that you want to contribute but
we're good
so I
had the conversation of like sharing my
concerns
um and the way that she approached it is
that this is
so her exact words were like this is
your inheritance of after I'm gone and
so I want to apply this to you for as a
gift so that I can see you guys enjoy it
um and have like a you know have
Financial stability in a house
and so I feel like I would be like
rejecting my mom in that if I say
no but I just feel like either way I
feel really guilty
yeah
I'm more I'm less worried about her the
gift I mean she's an adult she's gonna
do what she's gonna do
um I'm more worried about
um the strings that come with this kind
of gift
yeah
would there be strings to this kind of
gift
so I have really I don't I don't it's
the kind of okay
um yeah so I
so we have a conversation of like she
wants to give me this money and I said
um
sorry I I said we can talk about that
Mom and and you know like
two children and I want them to we can
start putting that into their college
savings
um or I can put it into an IRA and she
like made it specific to the down
payment of our house or a mortgage
whatever it comes at the time and so
I guess those expectations I do feel
like I have good boundaries with my mom
of like this is how far you come
into certain things and so I'm not
really sure I am I I'll just all I can
answer you on this one is
is just
how I would do this in my house and I am
not going to accept a gift that I am
fairly certain or that I know for
certain is going to hurt somebody else
for having given it
okay right yes Dave Ramsey wants to give
me a a big gift for my house I would
probably take that yeah right if a
family member of mine who I loved who I
know is struggling
um really wanted to give me a gift I
wouldn't be able to enjoy it I wouldn't
be able to sleep at night
yeah I'm trying to think at at worst
case scenario I might accept a gift and
and again I'm just talking out of my
butt right now
um actually I talked out of my butt most
of the time on the show but I was very
much right now I might put it in an
account and never spend it knowing that
this money's gonna go back to taking
care of this person at some point
maybe maybe
um
but and I get the sentiment
I get the sentiment that she wants to
see you guys enjoy this thing
I think that's where the harder
conversation is Mom the greatest
enjoyment we would have is knowing you
didn't owe anybody any money
yeah and then smiling go I don't want to
get a standoff on on you wanting to give
me a gift I'm so grateful
but the greatest gift you can give me is
not my house down payment we're doing
great the greatest gift you can give me
is you don't owe anybody anything ever
yeah okay
and she can write you a check and you
can leave it uncashed she can write you
a check and you can deposit it in an
account with the intent to never spend
it
um
but I mean it's not like she's going to
change check your bank records right
right
um and by the way if she says no you
can't use it for college funds you can't
use it for any other thing you have to
use it for this
I mean I
I'm not a huge fan of people telling me
what I can and can't do with my life I
don't like that
I like being able to do what I think is
right so anyway that I hope that helps I
I just know how messy those things are
and I'm sorry I wish I could give you
just a clean answer to it but the
cleanest answer I can give you is I'm
not going to let somebody hurt
themselves at my expense
and I don't want someone to use me
to feel better about themselves
like I don't want to be a tool or a
puzzle piece in somebody else's show
like that I don't want to be an actor in
somebody else's play
um
I want someone to want to bless me with
a gift and be able to bless me with a
gift and I want to be able to fully
receive that gift knowing the heart and
soul behind that thing not that
somebody's got some guilt that they
couldn't do something else a long time
ago or they've been struggling so
they're gonna make sure you don't
struggle that's that means you're
getting used for somebody else's
benefits they can feel good and I just
want to participate in that but I know
that's so hard with a mom that loves you
I know it's so so so so hard so I'm
sorry I can't give you like a more like
do this but that's that's the best
that's the best path I could give you
um let me know what you decide to do
because I'm I'm interested in in how
that conversation goes so holler back it
at Jenna um when you get a chance
because I want to know how that
conversation goes and where it heads off
from here but man being able to sit with
you actually do this hang on the line
I'm gonna send you a free one-year
Financial Peace University course my
friend Dave Ramsey
um
maybe you can offer that to your mom and
say Mom we got this for you this is a
gift all the lessons all the all the
courses everything we got this for you
this would be the greatest gift if you
went through this class and you took
this inheritance and you paid off
everything and I had the blessing of
knowing that my mom in her 60s and 70s
into retirement age was gonna be safe no
matter what she's gonna be safe that'd
be awesome